if you happen to be watching me now and
are in desperate need of a lifeboat
anywhere near Whitby in North Yorkshire
or your luck don't expect the brave men
and women of the RNLI to save your life
any time soon as they've lost half a
dozen of the bravest of the brave in a
row over coffee mugs yeah talk about a
storm in a teacup in the sort of regular
office banter and nonsense that relieves
the grueling tedium of work life a
couple of life boatman would be
exchanged gifts of mugs featuring images
of the mock tupper's semi naked women
now some ghastly pious senior female
member of start of staff declared this
could be a safeguarding risk if a visit
by schoolchildren alighted upon the
crockery so the two members of staff
were sacked four others have quit in
protest now much may be unknown about
the case however as the locals at Whitby
say this is totally compromised the
life-saving abilities of the lifeboat
surely this route is nothing more than a
mug's game the king of pubs thank you
well this this case has confused me
because from we don't know much about it
but from what we do know we know that
one of these men that was stood down as
the RNLI has said was volunteering for
them for 15 years it's a volunteer
organisation as a charity they've saved
kind of money inappropriate no no that's
why I'm saying I'm a bit confused
because I think there's only one there's
only one way which I can understand
what's going on here is that if it was
targeted abuse if one of the female
other volunteers had made a complaint
but we we haven't even heard their
attitude of two female colleagues said
they weren't if they said they were not
offending yeah so that's why I'm so
confused now you know just to give the
benefit of the doubt to the RN and I
let's hear well let's read their okay
what they've said about it they've said
these were serious conduct issues which
go beyond media speculation around the
production and use of offensive mugs one
volunteer was stood down for social
media activity which targeted a member
of the RNLI staff without their
knowledge and use graphic sexual images
which went far beyond banter as a
responsible employer we cannot take this
sort of behavior lightly the lifeboat
station should be an environment where
people are treated with dignity and
respect but I'm unaware as of yet of any
complaint
made by any female staff member which is
what's confusing me here is it somebody
becoming offended or somebody else's
behalf which was the difference which
would be different to targeted
harassment nick is growing the idea of
colleagues being treated with dignity
and respect I've decided to waive those
rules for you Nick have a look at what
we prepared for you Oh axle of mug there
is a realm of banter that can happen the
workplace but the are in a lie and we
don't know the facts but it made it very
clear that what happened that we don't
exactly know went beyond that that it
was directly targeted at a female staff
member it wasn't just a mug there was
social media activity but I do know that
one in three women in the workplace in
Britain have experienced sexual
harassment at work people making
unwanted jokes and I want to find that
such at the lowest level what is that
sexual possibly the stapler darling can
be comments about their body or their
sexuality can be pass me the stapler
darling it could also be that image on
the mug right there that's part of the
problem with that statistic four out of
five of them don't report it whether
whether you objectively deem it serious
or not they feel uncomfortable and
they're not reporting it because we
still have a culture in the web cabinet
where women who've resigned as a as a
result of it's supposed to look yeah and
quite rightly we say this is about mugs
and we haven't seen anything relax it's
not it's about social meter actually
between this is this is this is this is
the political correctness again all
public institutions have been hijacked
by politically correct idiots and what
the pclob
don't seem to get is the consequences of
what they're doing the consequences of
this is that that who's gonna be saving
lives and we'd be minus 6 men down who's
gonna want to join that team again the
whole community has just finished just
finished I was on a roll okay the whole
community is now is now against the RNLI
or in our in our workers all over the
country are considering quitting over
this because they're so angry about I'm
doing and let me finish and the
relations to them are in a lie
not saying we will never come again so
what good did this do in a moment
carefully you wanted to come in then I
was gonna say the consequences of this
are going to be that when people and
brave one volunteer with the RLI in
future they'll know that there is a zero
tolerance policy of sexual harassment in
the workplace
keep this absolutely in perspective we
are dealing with the RNLI
an institution that has saved over a
hundred and fifty thousand lives that is
relying entirely on volunteers yes no
public donation yes the public loves the
rni they support the honorably
appreciate their honor so I think this
should not overshadow the great work
that they do including these individuals
isn't it right so but based on where sit
where I said you've got to concede what
Carol said is that you know Whitby's
lost six volunteers and so what I was
saying is that surely there could have
been some measure taken like for example
slap on the wrists don't do this again
in the absence of a woman specifically
compared to both of you what happened
initially to sack them there hasn't been
a complaint Nick in his intro said there
was a ghastly pious smell started here
here do you know she's gasoline pies
what we do know is that she said it was
quote inappropriate crockery to demonize
the woman who calls this out if
perpetrators we could bring it coming
for here we are when you put that mug on
on the screen he like yeah of course now
it appears from what we know that no
specific female staff has come for
witnesses plate so it's the equivalent
now is the equivalent now somebody else
getting offended on mix behind us while
he's saying he wasn't offended and
kicking you off this panel show well I
like that idea
we are in Li pey the thick end of 40
slant for a safeguarding officer and so
they have to busy themselves with
something so they've busied themselves
with us a good boy logs with naked meets
the point Richard little John made in
his column they know we know the bet
that is very clear we don't know the
facts we don't know what actually
happened but there is this balance
between banter that has always taken out
my place in the workplace forever and
political correctness going too far this
is a case of political correctness going
to Utah so you're a team when we know
all the facts we don't know where as
offended by what you're about to see
this is there was at Warwick University
every year produced a naked calendar for
charity what do you think about these
pigs f we're fine improve who can't
handle nudity well I have a problem is
woman at the RNA lab was what I have a
problem with is behavior that makes
women feel uncomfortable in the
workplace we have a long history of that
in Britain we have a long history with
so many multiple by that I mean putting
Nick's face on a mug anyway we know that
what you said and you're correct in
saying that is if Nick took offense at
that and then made of you yeah if that
hasn't happened it's it right for a
superior to decide on his behalf that
he's been made to feel uncomfortable and
then kick you off you know what worries
me here is that we don't know the facts
and that's so in the absence of really
knowing the facts there's this instinct
to assume that the female staff member
reports is vastly important gotta get a
journalism don't worry about the fact we
do know we reported it was a boss and
found it we've got it we've got to stop
there